balder's gate 3 early access is coming
in september death loop is delayed until
next year
and today's batman teaser gave us
another teaser i'm chasity and this is
your save save for tuesday august 18th
you're hoping to play baldur's gate 3
this month you only have to wait a
little bit longer because the game hits
early access in late september
baldur's gate 3 early access starts on
pc and stadio on september 30th the date
was confirmed during the panel from hell
streaming during summer games
fest the panel began with a new cgi
trailer that showed a nautiloid ship
flying above
avernus the first layer of dungeons and
dragons nine hells
the game begins with you escaping that
ship and the early access game will
include the game's fall first act
it'll launch with five origin characters
a vampire elf rogue
a human wizard a gift warrior a half elf
cleric
and a human warlock and you can make
your own custom characters too
more details on races classes and
locations will be revealed closer to
launch
baldur's gate 3 is only planned for pc
and stadia right now but console
versions haven't been ruled out
adjusting to working from home has been
a challenge for numerous game devs
including arcane studios
their game death loop has officially
been delayed to 2021 death loop is the
next game from arcane studios makers of
dishonored and prey
it's a groundhog daylight game where an
assassin named colt takes out targets on
a deserted island that resets each day
you can also invade other people's games
as julia a counter-assassin who wants to
stop colt from reaching his targets
death loop has been delayed to q2 2021
which means it'll release on ps5 and pc
sometime from april to june of next year
the delay is due to development
difficulties rising from covet 19
as finishing the game while working from
home is taking longer than normal
arcane released a statement on twitter
saying quote this extra time will allow
our team to bring death loop's world to
life with as much character and fun
as you've come to expect from our team i
don't know about you but i love
dishonored and time loop movies so i'm
all
the first countdown on the official
batman teaser site ended resulting in
another teaser yesterday we talked about
the batman teaser site for a game
rumored to be called gotham knights
the countdown on the official site ended
but didn't reveal anything too
new now if you enter the code 761 you'll
unlock an image of a city and be
prompted to come back tomorrow
there are countdown timers for each day
for the rest of this week so it looks
like we're in for more teases until the
game is actually revealed
the dc fandom event is this saturday the
22nd and wb montreal has an event so
that's
probably where we'll see the game
actually revealed plus dc fandom will
also be delivering panels about dc
movies like wonder woman 1984 the
suicide squad the batman justice league
snyder cut and more
and for everything you need to know
about those go to gamespot universe
also while you're still here just a
reminder that we're still raising money
for charity with the gamespot store
head over to store.gamespot.com to buy
cool play for all merch including face
masks t-shirts
hoodies and a very rad skateboard all
proceeds go to charity until the end of
august so go to the store buy something
for yourself or a friend and help us
raise money for a good cause
and that's your save save for tuesday
i'm chasti you can find me on twitter
chastity underscore v or talking about
movies and tv shows over on gamespot
universe at youtube.com
gamespot universe i'll see you next time
[Music]
you